a gente saber duas coisas antes de ser
mãe que não frequenta o curso
especializado no assunto que vai receber
um produto inédito
munido de um completo sistema de emoções
e reações que deverá ser decodificado
várias vezes ao longo de uma vida mas
logo chegam os conselhos não solicitados
piorando a sensação de que tem algo que
vai acontecer
para complicar de vez a nossa vida
exemplos
prepare-se para nunca mais dormir ou
espere até chegar à adolescência é que
complica mesmo filho complica a vida da
gente e já na largada na infância com
essa história de não falar o que está
sentindo e depois quando mal começam a
se expressar tratam eles mesmos nos
passarem as notificações não solicitadas
a minha caçula disse aos três anos para
o pai que nunca mais e obedecê-lo
só quando ele mandava tomar sorvete viu
só que espero é a complicação não é só a
lidar com crianças espertinhos
adolescentes rebeldes nem as noites em
claro o desafio é cuidar dessa pessoa ou
dessas pessoas disse ao mesmo tempo
porque quando se torna a gente se torna
mãe a gente perde certas regalias
isso ficou claro pra mim no dia que eu
peguei minhas duas filhas combinando que
quando ela estiver em quartos separados
nenhuma entraria no quarto da outra sem
pedir permissão sem pelo menos bater na
porta
esse acordo foi feito na maior paz
parece está muito acostumado desse
procedimento habitual disse ótimo vamos
começar já com o meu quarto sob duas
crianças chorando com aquela cara de o
que você está falando ah eu não posso
fazer
sou mãe e eu sei por que passa por isso
a minha filha mais velha me deu
explicação
mãe ele carolina somos apenas irmãs você
é nossa mãe né
eu sou aquela pessoa que não tem
privacidade na própria casa nem fora
aliás que basta botar o pé na rua o
celular tocar são demandas que não
acabam nunca parece que só a nossa mãe
né
sabe onde está tudo mesmo sentar lá pra
ver e ainda que nosso pai esteja do lado
cheio de boa vontade
a verdade é que a vida de uma família
com criança pequena parece uma gincana e
sobra tarefa pra todo mundo tem missões
complicadas condições fáceis exemplo
onze da noite você lembra que esqueceu
dele agenda escolar
aí você descobre que uma menina precisa
levar uma fantasia do folclore
brasileiro
no dia seguinte ea outra tem que ao
prato da festa junina vai ter uma festa
interna
você se dá conta que não tenha endereço
os ingredientes nem o dom de improvisar
muito menos de cozinha é quando você
tenta encaixar essas demandas malucas na
sua vida
percebe que a jornada da escola não bate
com a jornada do trabalho que a
distância de nunca são levadas em conta
que o trânsito tampouco ajuda quem
trabalha tempo integral fica horas de
mais fora de casa
desde aquela sensação de que em algumas
áreas ficam descobertas deixa de ser um
pressentimento passa a ser uma certeza
porque a gente não pode tudo
quem leva a sério o papel de pai e mãe
sabe que educar é um processo que passa
por escolhas porque requer presença
diálogo muito afeto criatividade também
ajuda sempre
mas a gente é muito repetitivo repete
todos os dias as mesmas coisas porque dá
trabalho e explicar e comunicar a
criança aquilo que ela ainda não entende
é que é basicamente muita coisa
não é toa que quem dedica mais horas do
dia as crianças vai ficando curta eu sei
mas é normal não é coisa de gente
destemperada ok
e quem diz isso não sou eu é o único
lote o pai da psiquiatria infantil e
deixou um alerta pais normais perdem a
paciência com seus filhos se ficarem com
eles o tempo todo junto de si mas podem
ser mais amorosa feitosa se tiverem com
mais horas para si mesmo
concordo com ele só que nosso desafio
hoje ao criar filhos não é só a busca
tolerância busca de equilíbrio de
interesses
nós temos que lidar com uma leva inédita
de estudos e pesquisas que nos dizem o
tempo todo o que fazer eo que não fazer
com o filho para atingir esse ou aquele
objetivo é angustiante
na verdade a informação ela tem o seu
papel
ela entra lapidando o nosso bom senso e
não como uma camisa de força porque nós
precisamos sobretudo de inspiração
até porque nós temos filhos pequenos que
estão crescendo estamos ou vamos passar
por uma das fases mais dolorosas da vida
segunda psicanálise que é quando o filho
de cobre que nós não temos todas as
qualidades que ele tanto imaginava
de uma hora pra outra são os demitidos
do posto de heróis
no auge da raiva chegou a dizer que
somos os piores do mundo
uma comparação injusta porque também
estamos em busca de reconhecimento mas
eu tenho uma boa notícia
nós precisamos abraçar o conceito dos
pais suficientemente bons defendido por
rui recorde e que tem passado batido por
essa neura de acertar de fazer tudo
certinho como mandam os manuais sei lá
que alguém escreveu
a perfeição não vai ajudar mas bons
bastante são capazes de criar filhos
perfeitamente sadios porque as teorias
elas ajudam ainda bem que sabemos o
quanto a infância importante para nossa
saúde mental mas nada substitui a
experiência de lidar com o próprio filho
pequeno convívio que a gente aprende a
ser pai e mãe são essas crianças com
essa cara cheia de dúvidas de quem está
entendendo nada está acontecendo ao
redor que vai nos ensinar os segredos da
maternidade e da paternidade
o melhor é que elas fazem isso nos
inspirando a sermos pessoas melhores
porque eu tenho observado na minha casa
graças aos meus dois exemplares é que
criança tem muita facilidade pra rir e
pra sonhar é meio caminho andado para
duas virtudes altamente recomendadas por
essa jornada chamada vida que é o bom
humor ea capacidade de sonhar
o bom humor
é aquela sabedoria que nos falta muitas
vezes e hits mesmo é algo que a gente
pode aprender a fazer tanto quanto andar
de bicicleta
teve um dia que a minha filha mais velha
chegou da escola muito chateada que
tinha acontecido ela disse foi na aula
de música
ele tem 19 anos e ela quer ser cantora
eu pedi pra cantar a gente estava
formando uma banda tá aí o que aconteceu
eu fiquei com o chocalho
fiquei um pouco em silêncio é e tentando
ser neutro disse realmente tocar
chocalho é bem diferente de cantar não é
alguma coisa no olhar daquela menina me
disse essa história está virando piada
ea distância tão grande a expectativa ea
realidade que ela caiu na gargalhada e
me liberou r também né ea sensacional
você percebeu exato momento que uma
criança começa a aprender a arte de
tocar chocalho navita
quem nunca o bom humor ele transforma a
tragédia em comédia é o filtro que muda
o seu olhar sobre a história de permite
recontá-la se for necessário que ri de
si mesmo tem uma versão muito mais legal
para contar porque o que ficou desse
piso escala em casa enquanto aquino foi
a decepção de não ter sido a cantora
mas a lição de que desapontamentos
também tem seu lado engraçado melhor
tragicômico é a narrativa que muda e
narrativa faz toda a diferença
gabriel garcía márquez no início de sua
biografia ele faz uma ressalva muito
interessante ele diz o seguinte a vida
não é aquilo que a gente viveu mas
aquilo de que a gente recorda e como
recorda para contar depois a outra
virtude infantil que eu acho que faz
toda a diferença é sonhar crianças
sonham acordados domingo o tempo todo já
repararam lá em casa até hoje carolina
mais nova que está com seis anos têm
esse hábito de contar o sonho da noite
anterior em detalhes
são histórias mirabolantes fantasia e
realidade passado presente e futuro se
misturam em histórias incríveis
isso faz tão parte do nosso hábito já
que um dia intrigada ela me perguntou
mamãe adultos sonho também eu claro né
mas tenho que admitir pra mim mesma que
a gente não sonha com as crianças as
crianças sonham tanto desejam com tanto
ardor que elas defendem aquilo que elas
querem fazer com o corpo é físico elas
esperneiam batem o pé e nós eu não estou
sugerindo que você começa a se jogar no
chão do shopping toda vez que quiser
alguma coisa ok mas perguntem
honestamente tem algum sonho aí pelo
qual você seria capaz de desempenhar
você é tão fiel assim o seu desejo nós
somos apenas pais e mães muitos ainda
são apenas filhos companheiros
profissionais em busca de um rumo
pessoas desejosos de uma vida com
sentido e essa receita pode desandar
é muito fácil a gente se deixa
impressionar pelas adversidades pelas
dificuldades do caminho por mágoas de
relacionamentos desfeitos sonhos
abandonados metas nunca atingidos ou
sequer traçadas que vão tirando o brilho
de viver mas sonhar nos impede de entrar
no modo automático o sonho é o que vem
antes da realização e eu parar para
escutar as minhas filhas eu pude ouvir a
voz de uma outra criança que eu conhecia
muito pouco
eu mesmo eu era uma criança sonhadora
aqui estamos no futuro chegamos o que
fizemos com os nossos sonhos
foi a minha criança que fez arrumar um
espaço nessa gincana maluca de mulher
mãe que trabalha fora para dar conta da
escrita do meu primeiro livro porque a
minha criança disse eu vou ser a editora
não é coincidência eu tenho me dedicado
meu sonho e depois me tornar mãe porque
ficou mais fácil resgatar essa infância
quando as crianças sonham o tempo todo
do meu lado
a nossa história de vida marcada por
decisões conscientes e outras tantas que
tomamos muitas vezes sobre evitável
influência do acaso o fortuito está lá
atrás da cortina a nossa espreita
estamos no controle esses ingredientes
também valem para a vida dos nossos
filhos e educação que damos para eles
isso gera uma certa vulnerabilidade como
assim uma missão que dá tanto trabalho
na qual investimos tanto amor e não nos
dá nenhuma
dia no final pois é mas é uma história
que faz muito mais por nós mesmos então
nós podemos encará las sob uma nova
perspectiva de quem sabe que ao cuidar
de um filho cuida também da criança que
foi ainda é amplo sentido à própria
existência enquanto pratica virtude que
dão mais graça e leveza vida
então como sugerido por garcía márquez
poderemos barrar poderia barrar a
história dos nossos filhos não como um
tempo de sacrifícios mas como uma época
que nos deixou lições inesperadas como
sonhar mais e rir de nós mesmos
muito obrigada